you
[ __ ] don't get you fakin business
Jack Daniels gets you some fights this
week we've been here all week filming a
new show called epic chef so we're
taking our background in greasy
disgusting culinarian monstrosities and
kind of turning it into a competition so
basically each episode two contestants
go head head using the ingredients that
we supply them with and they have to
create something epic for the judges
each episode judges are different Harley
hosts and the rest of the crew is kind
of just here like to help out lend a
hand moral support but the judges have
been like different notable people each
episode the chefs that are competing are
not sure exactly where they found them
or how they got them but like we brought
in Duff from Ace of Cakes yesterday he
wasn't competing he was a judge and like
Timothy Ferriss is pretty well-known
he's judging right now so we have some
pretty like high quality chefs here to
critique the foo not make it may be like
if we do an all-star season he'll get
them to cook two days ago someone made
like a big castle or something and as
they were like taking it and
transporting it to the judging room it
looks at me and he's like man is this
not the craziest [ __ ] you've ever seen I
was like well no but maybe tops 80 once
you stuff like a bird in a bird in a
bird in a bird in a pig and then done
that 12 times asked the mouth then know
each contestants given a briefcase full
of bacon so we've had two three
contestants like just empty out the
briefcase that's been cool but no one's
done too overboard we're still same
every Tuesday Epic Meal Time episodes
this will be on a separate day same
channel we have a lot of ideas actually
this is one of the bigger ones from one
of the first ones we really wanted to
put priority on it's it's inspired off I
don't know if you ever seen this show
chopped on food network it's inspired
off that we like that show and we decide
like let's just make it give it that
dumb epicMealTime Flair none of us are
even like actual chefs or anything so
like for us to be judging this
competition it's not like we're trying
to like pretend like we know what we're
doing or pretend like we're actually DS
at all we're still like all douchebags
at the end of the day so this is
basically just an opportunity to like
see see what people can do some
creativity like yeah like you said
branch out like working with some other
people I just overall I thought it was a
good idea we're gonna try to like it set
some time to talk at Harley too but he
every time I see no reason every time
here he's not like kind of his persona
it's crazy he seems like almost kind of
like
yeah he's a user loud douchebag I drink
and yell yeah I also taste I'm not
really much of a judge though I like to
leave the judging up to our guest judges
so they can show they're shooting
personalities or personalities plenty of
it is yeah I'm having a great time I'll
beat you guys in a footrace no I just
I'll beat you and out of the bottom who
raised you at all he jus trust me he
stopped
I think he amps it up slightly when the
cameras rolled but it's for the most
part that's that's pretty much him we're
all pretty much like trying to be like
entertaining versions of ourselves I
guess sorry funny like muscles glasses
is really a piece of [ __ ] he hates
everything and everyone I'm talking real
life here off camera he hates everything
I've seen him tell like 11 year old
girls like asking for autographs and
tell them to [ __ ] off ice cream be
getting that right here let's go what's
good it has some calls right here how
much is anybody no sandwich running all
the time I bought oh there you go baby
David
is dulce
just get fake United that's not a good
guys peace out they fed up in every town
yeah good here good vegetarian shoulders
you got here what's this yeah cuts
cheese that kind of [ __ ] oh yeah chom
chom planning the [ __ ] best at juice
his name's amir atari yeah whoa that's
pretty great sorry that's a good what's
a pudding vegans or vegetarians in their
guts what's up yeah okay this this this
right here is Balthazar baltazar this is
baltazar Iago humble Blatche
i'd say like maybe like
Carlton Carlton clear water may be okay
with that not sure because any bacon is
better than no big oh by the way that's
the t-shirt copyright trademark let's
did that now I don't need any 11 room
that I already got her this morning so
that's a blast okay thank you
woman yes thanks for having us on gather
round to DeAndre bum get out your funky
races porno site if I appreciated